[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on this Thursday the 1st
of February
2024 my name is Freddy gray and I will
be your host
today on the show this week we will be
talking about stubbing out or stubbed
out which is the cover line of this
week's spectator Kate Andrews on the
dory's smoking ban and the threat to
Liberty we will then talk to ktie blls
and Anthony Seldon about the week in
politics and then we'll talk to our
wonderful columnist lonol shrier about
Donald Trump's trials and particularly
his case or the case against him from EG
Jean Carroll after that we'll turn our
attention to the Middle East and
specifically the nefarious activities of
Iran I will be discussing that with
Charlie gaml and lastly we'll talk about
Z xingping who is arguably or probably
even the most powerful human being on
the planet at the moment uh Charles
Parton has written a book review about
the way he thinks and the way the
Chinese Communist Party thinks we'll be
discussing that
before we begin though I must urge you
to subscribe to spectator TV and you can
do that by hitting the Subscribe button
at the bottom of your screen uh and the
bell icon after that to make sure that
you get a reminder every time we release
a new episode rishy sunak may not have
achieved very much in his Premiership so
far uh but one thing he has made
progress on uh is the war against
smoking which uh we understand is
something something he feels quite
strongly about uh this week the
government confirmed that it would be
banning disposable Vapes and cracking
down on other vape flavors and so on
which are thought to be particularly uh
attractive and therefore dangerous to
children and this is on the back of his
plan uh which he announced at thory
Party Conference to phase out uh smoking
legal smoking in Britain uh to discuss
this I'm joined by Kate Andrews our
economics editor who has written a cover
piece called stubbed out uh for the
spectator this week and Professor
Dominic Wilkinson who is a professor of
medical ethics at Oxford
University Kate uh this ban or this move
against smoking is popular uh it's one
of the things the government is doing
that seems to be
well-liked um why do you oppose it so
much yes you're right Freddy it is very
popular it's not terribly surprising
although disappointing that the majority
of people support a Crackdown on the way
that other people might live their lives
because we are talking about a ban for
everybody on disposable Vapes a
Crackdown on flavoring and packaging but
that is only part of the tobacco and
Vapes bill which we are expecting this
month in the House of Commons the
centerpiece of that is a ban on anybody
born after January 2009 from ever
legally purchasing a packet of
cigarettes this may be expanded to other
tobacco products it could include cigars
it could include SHO
uh could include heat not burn products
we're not sure what's going to be in
those details yet but what it seems the
public support is the idea that the Next
Generation who can't even really be
pulled yet on this issue to be asked how
they might feel about this should not be
able to legally purchase cigarettes and
what the cover piece looks at is not any
kind of defensive smoking I think we all
hope that the Next Generation goes smoke
free if you're a smoker you are likely
to die earlier you're likely to have all
kinds of Health complications it's not
any kind of pro smoking argument it's a
much more fundamental question about
Liberty and deciding One's Own Destiny
and what precedent this sets if you
start bringing in two tiers of Rights
not for children but for adults for
people who will one day be 18 then 35
then 45 than 90 what if they have to
live a different way what if they don't
have the same consumer rights as one of
their peers as somebody who is simply
onee older than them is that the kind of
society we want to live in and might
another government take this Playbook
and expand it to other areas of Our
Lives to food to drink it doesn't seem
improbable that something like that
could happen so it's not a defense of
smoking it's it's a defense of people
being able in a free Society in a
liberal Society to sometimes make bad
decisions to make decisions that aren't
good for them uh we don't want children
making those decisions and thankfully we
have laws for that children aren't
allowed to buy Vapes they're not allowed
to buy cigarettes when they're adults
should they make their own decisions or
should the government and members of the
public now make it for them and I argue
they shouldn't they should be able to
make their own choices good and bad Kate
you are an American and to some extent
uh Liberty is or libertarianism is in
your DNA and particularly in yours uh I
can say that knowing you quite well um
does it strike you as odd that this is a
British ban and that British people seem
so enthusiastic about it because as you
say in your piece we are supposed to be
the sort of the the country that uh
engineered uh the Enlightenment and
freedom yes and no
I suppose the negative answer to that is
if we look at what happened during
lockdown there was huge public appetite
for the government to curb freedom for
the government to uh tell not just
ourselves but our neighbors what they
can and cannot do there was actually a
poll from the end of last year so well
after the height of the pandemic showing
that roughly a quarter of respondents
still wanted the rule of six where only
six people could legally meet up
together a quarter of people want
nightclub shut there is that
authoritarian streak that that runs uh
runs among people um but I suppose I I
am surprised in the sense that of of
course Britain um has has the spirit of
of Freedom it's something that it's
quite famous for all around the world as
you just said there Freddy a lot of the
Notions of freedom and what a liberal
society means were thought up and
founded in the UK and exported to the ex
rest of the world in terms of those
ideals I think Americans look at the UK
and and and and feel that way to a
certain extent um and in that sense it
is surprising and disappointing I mean
for Winston Churchill the cigar was a
symbol of of Liberty and there's a quote
in the piece about how he saw it as a
sacred right to be able to have a cigar
and unfortunately the you know what's
sacred in the UK at the moment seems to
be the National Health Service but even
on that ground it's really hard to
justify a smoking ban the tax that
cigarettes brings in covers smokers I
think three times to what they cost the
NHS again these aren't these aren't nice
things you know we we don't want people
coming into the NHS with diseases that
they get from cigarettes we don't
encourage this nobody wants this to be
happening it's a question of what you're
allowed to do in a free society and
whether or not your age uh when you're
an adult not when you're a child when
you're adult should determine that
Dominic as a medical ethicist can you
reply to Kate's point there I mean does
is this not a question of autonomy and
should we not have uh the freedom to
choose what we do with our own bodies um
whether that's harmful or not well I
mean as in many areas of life freedom is
one important value but it's not the
only important value and there are
Justified limits to our freedom one
potential and one potential limit on
which most people agree though some more
extreme Libertarians don't is that our
freedoms are justifiably limited when
they would cause harm to others and of
course we're very familiar and Winston
Church wouldn't I don't think recognize
uh um with with a restriction on our
personal Liberty for the sake of others
in terms of where people can smoke so
our our society's changed drastically in
in where people can smoke for the very
reason that one individual's choice will
negatively affect other people's Health
the harm to other people is one reason
why we might think that individual
liberty could be justifiably uh limited
here here's another reason so uh so
Liberty is important but there's another
value which is the health and wellbeing
of our population our Public Health
System is based on how do we promote
people living long happy healthy lives
and many of the things that many of the
effective ways of promoting the health
of our population actually involve
restricting our choices in some ways of
course some some things are more
restrictive of our choices than others
but when we for example limit where you
can buy things or we put taxes on those
uh on those products or we require uh we
limit advertising or we we put warnings
on them all of those affect our choices
often in less Frank ways than a ban
would but those are restrictions on
choices are they Justified or not well
arguably they are if we balance public
health benefit there's another
significant Public Health argument that
doesn't get uh recognized I think by the
the Libertarians which is that the the
harms of smoking fall very unequally um
those who uh who who sustain many of the
long-term Health consequences are those
who who are socioeconomically
disadvantaged and we could talk I'm sure
at length about why that is but the the
the structure of our society is such
that this like many other health burdens
Falls very unevenly but the central
question if if if I may um the qu the
central question about freedom I think
gets interesting in a number number of
ways so so one is not every freedom is
the same some freedoms are bigger than
others some freedoms are more important
than others so um if the government was
talking about restricting our freedom to
for example express our political views
or uh be part of a religion or to
associate with others those are very
significant meaningful
freedoms I I take Kate's argument about
government governmental interference but
what we're talking about here is the
freedom to burn a piece of of vegetation
in our mouth wrapped in a piece of paper
I mean yes it's a sacrifice of our
freedom but maybe it's a freedom that's
worth giving up one of the one of the
really interesting things here is that
tobacco is addictive it's intensely
addictive so what we're talking about
here is a freedom a freedom to make
choices when when our choices are un
unburdened but that subsequently become
enormously affected by by the the drive
to continue to smoke and there's there's
an argument that some of the public
health people people have have made that
that this type of prohibition is freedom
enhancing um and it's Freedom enhancing
in two straightforward ways one is it
frees us from something that will
restrict our freedom which is an
addiction the second is that by giving
us a longer healthier life it frees Us
in other ways it frees us for example to
get to see our grandchildren it frees us
to live longer healthier lives there's
an interesting uh point that
Libertarians often don't recognize which
is that our freedom is often restricted
by the natural world they often talk
about freedom from
interference but sometimes our
government needs to do things to make us
free for example to which the Americans
don't particularly except to to support
a a a fundamental right to to health
care so that people are free by virtue
of not having an overwhelming illness
not having to to Fork out to pay for
basic medic
ation uh I take all those points uh I
think uh rather than addressing myself
I'll let Kate uh uh
reply well I I'll jump into a few points
there so you talk about negative
externalities when it comes to smoking
and I think that it certainly in terms
of the fiscal perspective those are more
than covered as I said cigarette
receipts in the last fiscal year brought
in about 10 billion pounds H and that
covers smokers when it comes to their
NHS cost more than three times and it's
very important that you that you address
that and and cover that we should know
that the government's plans to ban
smoking for the next generation are not
targeted at parents now who might be
smoking around their kids or how we
actually prevent kids from secondhand
smoke they're targeted at telling future
adults what to do um I think you make an
interesting point about um those who are
disadvantaged in society and it's an
important Point those uh who are often
affected by the negative impact of
cigarettes those who might enjoy
cigarettes might be on the the more
disadvantage end of the spectrum I do
not think it is the place for people who
might be in a better position to tell
others how to live their lives and I
think that actually there's there's a
real sense of of arrogance and hubris
about that and that point about
happiness I I I want to come back to
last um you say that we can free people
from addiction well let's ban fatty
foods let's ban salt let's ban sugar
let's ban alcohol uh let's ban men and
women who are bad for us let's ban
absolutely everything that we can uh
that might cause us to have a a feeling
of impulse a feeling of want uh it's
distracting it's not good for
productivity the idea that uh you go
around picking and choosing which
addictions you don't like and perhaps
which addictions you do coffee tea
caffeine um that's not for any
government to decide that's for an
individual to decide um you mentioned
the right to healthcare there and you're
right in the United States that isn't
taken so seriously it is the exception
in the developed world to
to countries that that don't take their
healthare seriously particularly
providing universal access to healthare
that is an incredibly important
principle it should not be used as a
stick with which to hit people though
you should not be able to use your
health care System to tell people what
to do or how to live their lives that is
you living and working for the Health
Care System um it is you organizing your
life around a healthare system something
many of us did for practically all of us
did for for the better part of two years
during the pandemic but that's that's
not how we live our lives I I think the
most important Point here for me though
is that one about happiness I would like
to live along happy healthy life I'm not
a smoker um and that is a factor for me
I do not think I have the recipe for a
long happy and healthy life though
particularly that happy point I don't
think I have any particular recipe to
tell other people how to live a happy
life I don't know why somebody might
choose to smoke why somebody might
choose to smoke 20 30 cigarettes a day
um I wish they wouldn't I I think we all
know the health implications of that I
think smokers know the health
implications of that they can't pick up
a cigarette packet now without knowing
the health implications of that um but
it's not for me to tell them what kind
of Life to Live and it is certainly more
importantly not for a government to ban
them from doing what brings them Joy
even if it's fleeting even if it's a
moment of of happiness that they might
get from that cigarette
um I don't think this is just an issue
for Libertarians or people who are on
the you know more radical end of the
Liberty Spectrum I think people have to
sit back and think what what role do you
really want the state to play do you
really want the state telling adults
what they can and cannot consume and do
you want them telling certain adults
what they can and cannot consume because
plenty of adults will be able to
continue to buy cigarettes it is their
peers who who won't be able to buy
cigarettes uh and for me that is a that
is a huge inequality it's a huge problem
and it's also a playbook for a labor
party that might decide to tackle food
that might decide to tackle alcohol that
might decide that they want to Target
whatever they consider to be dangerous
at the time so you know it might not be
cigarettes for our viewers watching it
might be something else and I I don't
think they should assume that that's
safe from The Nanny State when there's
this new playbook going around that just
says well you don't like it ban it for
people who can't vote yet ban it for
people who can't be pulled yet who don't
have a voice who don't have a say I
think it's really important in a free
society that we stand up and it's
difficult that we stand up for the bad
options sometimes the options to consume
things you shouldn't the options to gain
weight the options to be offensive the
options to say horrible things these are
the difficult things to defend and these
are the things that we must defend
because that is what it means to live in
a free
Society Dominic uh I might just ask you
actually do you think the the the
arguments you put forward the in favor
of banning smoking uh would you apply
them to something like alcohol or other
addictive things that could be harmful
well and we we're focused very much on
alcoh on not on alcohol on on cigarettes
um Freudian slip peps we're focusing
very much on on cigarettes and I think
it's important with with any separate
case to look at whether the the
arguments work whether there are
consistency based Arguments for doing
the same approach or whether indeed
there are there are relevant differences
um I I think we shouldn't take the the
uh be drawn into these types of slip of
slippery slope arguments that if if you
uh allow a generational ban on smoking
that you're going to be led down this
path to to restrictions on on different
types of food um if we think that those
are relevantly different then we can
make distinguish distinctions between
them as indeed we already do uh obvious
viously um the the basic arguments that
ker is making in terms of people's
freedoms to to make bad choices to
freedoms to become addicted freedoms uh
to to take things that are bad for them
apply to all sorts of things that we
currently prohibit that we currently
don't allow people to purchase um and I
think there's there's this really
interesting uh tension between moves in
some parts of the world towards decri
decriminalization and liberalization
of all sorts of drugs that are currently
illegal and and a kind of opposite
approach
towards more restrictions more legal
restrictions on on drugs I think what
one of the interesting things and I
think it's we haven't quite got to the
grips with it about the proposed ban is
is its generational nature um and it's
not simply about uh imposing a ban on
those who can't currently vote it's
about saying if we're going to impose a
restriction uh can we do so in a way
that is least burdensome on the
population if if we take those who are
currently IND addicted imposing a ban
will be be a very significant effect on
their lifestyle it'll it'll be
incredibly difficult for them but if we
take those who are not yet addicted and
we remove from them a choice a choice
that that cases fully accepted is bad
for them um that that will likely cause
them harm in the long term that that
many have acknowledged people will
likely regret in the
future that that's importantly different
taking away that choice uh than taking
away something that people already have
access to so that's the reason that's
the fundamental reason for why not take
away everything why not take away
everything I mean you say the slippery
slope argument is is a bit of a stretch
but the labor party are already looking
at Food they've been very clear about
that that might be their focus why not
take away everything from the
14-year-old who a want one day B 18 why
not take away booze why not take away
high sugar products you say they're not
exposed to these things yet why not take
those away too well again I mean I think
what what we need to look at to what
what we're focused on is this question
about tobacco the the harms are very are
very clear and and except nobody uh
disputes the the very significant health
health based times it's very easy
because tobacco is discreet and we can
uh uh we can separate it from other
elements of our life and obviously food
exists on a spectrum it's much more
challenging to to to say alcohol alcohol
is a much bigger killer why not just say
now you would B alcohol for all future
18y olds so the the the point about
alcohol of course is is that we would
need to have a separate debate
but if it were chosen to introduce
generational ban on on Tobacco that
doesn't mean that we have to or that
we're led to introduce a ban on alcohol
there there are reasons in favor of it
there are reasons which you've
articulated against it we we need to
take each issue on its merits and not
get uh drawn into thinking that we have
to ban everything or nothing uh we
already ban uh these other drugs to take
your argument if we should take the
libertarian approach we should uh
immediately liberalize access to all
these other currently illegal drugs now
again Libertarians have no problem with
that um but there's a there's a cost
there's a cost to people's lives a very
substantial cost in terms of their
health and well-being and we have to
decide as a society how much do we about
do we value these types of freedoms
against these very significant Health uh
benefits well I would take a more
liberal approach to drugs and be
consistent on that issue I think that
the idea that you would allow some
people to consume certain things and
allow people one year younger to not do
so um is an even bigger Point here that
is the point about equality and fairness
and the law applying equally to adults
and this government is going to set a
precedent that it doesn't have to and I
think anybody regardless of what they
think about drugs or smoking or alcohol
should be incredibly concerned about
that precedent so so the equality
argument I think is is a weak one
because there are all sorts of laws that
we
apply we apply
to to selectively to to some people so
for example you you have access to a
pension at a particular age you have
access to uh to the ability to vote or
to drive or to start smoking at a
particular age now there's a reason for
those arbitrary Lines no no no hold on I
want to be very clear though that's I
think that's moddeling things everyone
gets to vote at the same age everybody
in theory if they can pass their test
gets to drive at the same age we are
talking about a policy in which you
reach a certain age and every year that
it's legal is going to be one year above
you I'm not talking about the
arbitrariness uh yes you're right why
not 17 why not 19 I'm talking about the
fact that we're going to live in a world
where some people can consume a legal
product some people can buy over the
counter a legal product and some people
cannot it is not the case that the
voting age is going to raise one year
every year as so somebody can never
reach it it is not the case that to get
your driver's license you are going to
have to reach a year in which you're
never going to be able to reach that
will be true of cigarettes that makes it
fundamentally different and and what it
means is that our children will never be
in a position where legally they're able
to access uh this incredibly addictive
substance now the question is is that
something that we want to to create for
our children or not um that there are
some good reasons I've articulated them
for thinking that's actually an
incredibly good future society that we
uh and the maybe the way to reach a
future Society where where people are
not addicted don't uh don't desire
cigarettes is via this staged process
where we have a horizon that moves away
from young people now um but they
they're never in a position to legally
access uh cigarettes and there reasons
to think it's
orwellian well I do think uh we are in
danger of being on a slippery slope uh
towards an argument that will never end
um but we have to wrap it up there sadly
it is a very interesting discussion uh
and thank you Dominic for uh coming in
to to coming on to The Spectator to uh
take uh the position that you did and uh
thank you Kate as
always now let's talk about the week in
Westminster and uh it's been another uh
inauspicious week for rishy sunk uh I
would say there's been a few positive
stories um about boats uh illegal Boat
Crossings going down and agreements with
the French um but generally uh the
picture for rashak is looking
increasingly Bleak his personal approval
ratings are getting lower and lower um
and there was talk this week uh about a
possible coup against him this has been
Mur there have been murmurings of this
uh in Westminster for a while now and
they seem to be growing a little bit
louder um I'm joined to discuss this by
Katy Bulls uh our political editor and
Anthony Seldon who is the head of epson
College um as well as a biographer of
many prime
ministers um ktie uh first of all the
the K Bok uh sort of uh Insurrection is
that uh a real
deal I don't think it's real yet I think
the question is do the plotters um have
much to back their plans or their dreams
or rather they just a relatively small
number of figures some Tory MPS some
former advisors some former Tory donors
who would like to cause the Prime
Minister troubles to the point they
asked him but are more likely to just
cause him Pro troubles and lead to a
situation whereby it's even harder for
the Tories to limit their losses let
alone turn things around at the next
election as I wrote I think at the
beginning of the year it did feel as
though R deide is in the air I think
that has grown to a degree but as much
as we talk about these plotters who want
to bring down rishy sunak there's also
there almost sense of hon and huitt to
them if we go back to H the failed
attempt to ask Gordon Brown in an
election year because in an election
years it's really hard to get rid of a
prime minister um the saying goes you
know once you have had a confidence vote
in your leadership has not yet happened
for richy sunak happened to Teresa may
happened to Boris Johnson it doesn't
really matter if you win it you're on
borrowed time and that was certainly the
case with uh rich predecessors however
the point is you could still potentially
get to a point where there was a
confidence vote but then the Prime
Minister had just to limp on a couple of
months to an election so it's a slightly
different setting and scenario and I
think what we're seeing now when it
comes to the plotters is people saying
well we get it you don't like rishy
sunak Simon Clark said he should go no
one followed him who do you really think
is going to step in and transform the
tor's uh you know fortunes if they have
a situation when they go into their
fourth leader in 2 years is that's where
Camy bedo name keeps coming up so adab
bravman doesn't really have the support
across the party and therefore you have
a situation where I think probably the
most pragmatic or the option that would
have the highest chance of working would
be someone like KY bog who would appeal
to parts of the right though not all of
them and also be able to carry some of
the center so go vites and so forth now
the slight catch is as it stands Camy
Bok keeps saying she does not want to be
part of the plot so you have for example
stories today saying plotters have set
their sights on KY Bok and then you get
to the third line and it says KY Bok
says she wants nothing to do with the
plots so is Camy Bok who has been
discovered to be in a group WhatsApp
group titled evil plotters really you
know someone who is surv surrounding
herself with evil plotters or is this a
plot that just isn't going anywhere
anytime
soon presumably Anthony uh C Bok would
be foolish uh to sort of move against
Rishi sunak now given that the Tories
are heading for uh Landslide defeat and
so the obvious thing to do would be to
wait uh for the Tories to be beaten in
general election unless something very
peculiar happens in the next few months
um and then make a move uh do so do you
read much into it at
all so I think that uh there is
absolutely no end no bottom to the
stupidity and the total lack of uh any
historical grasp of the
conservatives I think we have to see
that not since the conservative party
was formed in 1832 has it ever been so
frat fordal and um divided over what it
believes in that it has been since
2010 it's already had five Prime
Ministers uh the notion the notion that
a six will come along and suddenly find
the money
which is not there and the policies
which are not there and the new voters
who are not there to transform the
prospects is completely uh out of La La
Land uh it will be a um Fiasco if it
happens I don't think it happens I think
uh perhaps like Katie that they are
positioning for what's going to happen
after the likely general election defeat
of course Camy Bok says um I'm nothing
to do with these plotters I mean uh
whoever would have imagined that uh she
would be doing anything less but if she
really was against it she could do much
more to suppress it wouldn't she uh so I
think it's all about uh postgenal
election defeat uh positioning uh but I
think it does say a lot about the state
of the conservative party I mean what on
Earth does the conservative party
believe in um and uh when is the
conservative party um truly itself who
are its stable voters it Bears almost no
resemblance to the conservative party
that was Empower Between 1979 and 97 or
between 1951 and 1964 or the inter War
years or in the whole long conservative
century when the conservative party
dominated the 20th century it's uh it's
something different to be honest what it
is I don't quite know I don't think
though that anyone quite knows
uh Katie can you give us a bit of an
Insight uh onto the relationship between
Rishi sunak and kmy Bok if indeed k b is
uh a likely uh successor um k b of
course is a former spectator
employee uh and you know can you give us
a sense of whether those two because
they have been quite uh close in the
past have they not well they've been
close colleagues I think though famously
Cammy B was quite brutal to R during the
last leadership contest when during a
debate each of the candidates was
encouraged to ask another candidate a
question and some of them went for quite
silly light things and then K Camy Bok
who had worked in the treasury alongside
RI turned around and asked him a pretty
hostile question on Co fraud and why he
hadn't done a better job and I think it
was after this question that the they
almost walked back from making these
debates so Blue on Blue because of the
damage it might cause coming back
together after a contest now of course
Liz trust won the contest and there was
more infighting to follow and but I
think it gives you a sign that I think
KY B knock straight talking nature some
might put it others uh I think you
probably less fond of her might say she
at times can be quite abrupt um does
mean I think that she ends up having
these very direct exchanges with
colleagues I think when it comes to
Rishi cak and Camy B kno's um
relationship now he is prime minister
she has um you know an important job as
business
secretary um I think that as for how
warm things are there's definitely been
reports of tensions at times when you
think about things like um the India
trade deal sometimes
cptpp the question of being which I
think some of this is natural
departments coming up against the center
which is uh a feeling that Downing
Street does not consult enough for
example or um that is not working to the
timetable of the Departments when of
course D stre is you know working on its
own own priorities so I think a few
things like that have come up and
generally uh those around the cabinet
table can say that they find it hard to
you know to reach the Prime Minister
though I do think that has tends to be a
very common complaint if we think about
the past handful of Tory Prime Ministers
we have had um and then I think there's
always something which is when you are
in that position which who who are your
potential successes and there's always I
think a certain power and threat in h in
being the person who is at the top of
the conservative home you know cabinet
League table who was always on the
higher end when the leader tends to be
much more in the negative going up and
down which is currently the situation
for richy sunak uh one of his interests
Katie is fasting uh we've learned
recently U we should wrap this up soon
but I wanted to get your view on this
quickly do you think uh it's healthy for
a prime minister to not eat for 36 hours
much as we admire his slender uh
appearance he has said he does have the
occasional nut um so clearly he's living
on the edge when it comes to that 36
hour fast um naughty I don't suppose
when when when I think about rich and
his fast I don't think it makes him less
equipped to be prime minister I just
presume there's something different
going on with him than there is with me
I personally can not eat for 36 hours
and still I mean even be polite to
people let alone run a country um but
but I think um in that sense I think
he's been doing it so long maybe that is
why he's called Tachi is because he's
not eating for such a period of time
maybe he would have a more cheerful
demeanor sometimes when he's you know
under stress from persistent questions
from the Press but I don't look at him
and think he looks very frail and know
he's going to faint so it isn't causing
me great concern when it comes to that
when it comes to the things I think
about his Premiership and where it is
doing well and where it is not doing
well it it isn't a top on Isa list uh
scanning through quickly in my head I
can think come up with Stafford Crips
who was uh labor Chancellor under
Clement Atley who who ate a lot of
carrots and I'm sure fasted and had a
reputation for being uh a bit of a
faddist uh but look in general I think
that um fasting is is a great thing to
do not the least keeping as much of a
distance between your uh dinner and
breakfast we know that uh medically
that's good for you uh 36 hours I think
is perhaps push pushing that a little
bit far yes I certainly need to fast a
bit more um thank you both very much uh
for coming
on let's move on to Donald Trump and the
trials of Donald Trump or in particular
we want to discuss one trial uh one of
Donald Trump's many trials I should say
uh on Friday he was ordered to pay more
than $80 million to eege Caroll uh who's
a writer who alleges that more than 25
years ago um she can't be too specific
about the date she can't remember but
Trump uh sexually assaulted her uh and
he was found to be liable for rape uh a
few months ago and then last week found
to be liable again uh for defaming her
uh and this is a civil it's important to
point out this is a civil case not a
criminal case uh but nonetheless an80
million payment is Big Money even for
someone like Donald Trump I'm joined by
the wonderful lion Sher our much loved
columnist who has written a great piece
about this again uh her column always
good I'm sorry I'm being overly
flattering but there we go um uh uh
about this this week um Lionel the
headline of your piece is can Donald
Trump get a fair trial uh it's a good
headline but it does seem to be a bit to
one of those questions to which the
answer is
no oh almost always when uh when
headlines are posed as a question the
answer is obvious half the time I don't
read the article yeah it's like no next
um I mean the irony is that uh Americans
have always prided themselves on this
notion that all are equal before the law
and what we usually mean by that is that
people in positions of privilege who are
wealthy who are influential are not
going to be treated as if they're
special they're not going to get any
concessions they have to meet the same
standards as everyone else and this is
one of those
odd situations where I think being
someone who is uh influential and uh is
a a celebrity as well as you know
uh at this point in the
polls advantage to become president of
the United States this this
unusual uh appearance of privilege is
actually a disadvantage for Trump and in
means that uh he can't be tried like
just anyone else and there's there's no
way that anybody in any of these trials
jurors or or judges don't have an
opinion about him to begin with you
you're not going to be able to find a
jury anywhere that that approaches
Donald Trump in a state of Innocence yes
well we better be careful here in case
we have to pay EEG Carol 80 million know
we should we should I think I mean let's
be clear that we don't know we can't
prove or disprove uh the allegation and
neither can she because there's there's
no evidence uh for it Beyond her word
and the testimony of two of her friends
um who Their Own Story got some scrutiny
during the trial and but what we can say
is that uh she um is is a a writer of
sort of uh a lot of sort of erotic
fantasy she wrote a uh Hunter Thompson a
book about Hunter S Thompson in which
she sort of fantasized about being raped
by hunterz Thompson um she didn't uh I
think it's confirmed now that she in
fact I know it's confirmed now that she
had the idea to uh Sue Donald Trump for
rape uh after going to a a resistance
party resistance being the sort of
anti-trump uh movement she went to a
resistant party in New York and George
Conway uh the husband of Kellan Conway
who uh is very anti-trump uh suggested
it to her um it's not a sort of normal
uh rape uh story um and it's not uh even
a normal historic rape allegation it's a
very peculiar one and egene Carol I
think she's quite um amusingly eccentric
by the looks of her but she is it's not
your it's not your kind of your classic
story is
it well first off of course it's too old
um she waited a very long time to bring
these charges and we should note that uh
even in in civil terms uh the statute of
limitations had run out and this case
was only possible because in the wake of
me too New York passed a law that made
it possible for created a one-time
window uh for sexual abuse victims to um
bring their charges to court in defiance
of the statute of limitations having run
out
uh and I question that law I mean it's a
classic uh you
know legislation passed in a state of
social hysteria speaking to the urgency
of the immediate moment and that's a
formula for bad legislation I think that
uh statute of limitations on
sexual abuse charges are a good idea
because uh memories fade and and and
evidence becomes non-existent this is a
very good example there is no material
evidence for this ever having occurred
um aside from her having confided in a
couple of her friends uh after after it
it occurred so uh that's why it would
never have stood up in Criminal Court
where you have to have uh an
overwhelming uh
certainty of guilt whereas in Civil
Court it only has to be Beyond 50%
likely that this person is guilty um
which is much looser and also further
makes this the size of this award absurd
I think it's worth asking the question
as to whether or not uh aene Carrol
would ever have brought this suit if it
weren't Donald Trump this is another
example of it's he's not he's not being
being protected because of his
possession he's being attacked because
of his possession yes and so you think
the the combination of it being Trump
and this uh new New York law adult
survivors law um makes it impossible but
I mean the adult survivors law could
actually be problematic for anyone
really because it depends on a on a
jury um and in New York uh you're quite
likely to get a a jury that would be
full of people who believe who think
that Belial women uh is is a reasonable
position um I think of all places Trump
or someone like him does not have a
chance in New York state I mean it's
it's chalk full of Democrats yes and uh
and it's run by an attorney general who
has pretty much uh come to power uh on a
pledge to get Donald
Trump yes which seems vaguely illegal to
me I just I don't know how that's
possible that you can um then you can
run on a platform of going after a
particular citizen in in the judicial
system and I you know this is part of a
larger uh picture because of course
there are those four other um trials and
the 91 charges that we keep hearing
about and you know it smells bad
I uh I I agree with the what has become
a mainstream view uh on on the right of
Center that uh this is not uh the way
even if you want to this is not the way
to take down Donald Trump you should he
should be deated he should be defeated
in The Ballot Box and not not in the
courts and and I think because Democrats
are not liking the look of the polls
they're getting more and more motivated
to go after Trump in the courts uh
including by taking him off the ballot
altogether for example in in Colorado
and Maine and I just think this whole
approach is wrongheaded uh it looks
genuinely anti-democratic from people
who never shut up about democracy yes
and not only is it failing to stop trump
it could actually help him win of course
yeah and it you know it feeds all the
paranoia on the right that the Democrats
are out to get Trump by any means
possible and I think they're right yeah
could you give us a little bit of an
insight as an American who knows Britain
uh very well um on the ways different
ways in which Americans and Brits think
about the law because it's often seemed
to me that Americans accept at some
level that their legal system is more
politicized because it is um and then it
means that when Brits look at legal
American stories we assume assume that
the law has a sort of Integrity that
perhaps Americans don't give it is that
a fair thing to
say maybe but I think that there's a
politicized element in the UK also
especially now that you have a supreme
court uh the decisions around brexit
were highly political and uh maybe that
was new to a a lot of Britain uh that
the the courts have their own opinions I
think to completely trust any justice
system as unpolitical is naive because
it's run by people and people have
opinions and and and they have certain
outcomes that they
prefer uh going in so there's there's
there's a political element to it anyway
and the all that neutrality is a
conceit so
and you know obviously with the
situation of the Supreme Court in the US
uh it because Justices are appointed by
a particular president with a particular
Viewpoint and party uh so the court is
is eternally divided between liberals
and
conservatives uh yeah from a distance it
it looks bad but I don't think it's that
different in the UK uh and lo I know LEL
I know it's uh very rude to ask people
how they're going to vote and I I won't
do that directly but certainly four
years ago you supported Joe Biden over
Donald Trump uh I get you said at the
beginning you're not you're not a trump
so we we I get that but do you really
think uh four more years of Joe Biden
would be uh uh better than more years of
Donald Trump I think four more years of
Joe Biden will will or would be a
catastroph
I there is no good outcome for this
election unless something changes the
number of people who are convinced that
at least the Democrats are going to
replace Biden at the last minute is is
very high and I don't know what I I
can't tell the difference between uh
sound intuition in this case and wishful
thinking because people are so desperate
that Biden not run again and especially
with Harris as his vice president and as
I understand the reasoning uh on the
Democratic side it's oh you know you you
can't uh push Biden into stepping down
because then there would be this
obligation to take kamla Harris who
would be roundly defeated against dog
catcher I mean anybody she she would
lose I guarantee you to
anybody um because you know she's
part black and part Indian and she's the
first female vice president and you
can't insult these groups of people I
think that's a false I think that's a
false assumption I think she's so widely
disliked that that includes a huge
number of black people and Indian people
and women so uh so that that's that's a
false assumption but that's that's the
that's the logic According to which you
know against guess the Heavies in the
Democratic party have have not leaned
very hard on him to to reconsider but uh
the
this if it goes ahead Trump and Biden
there is no way I'm I'm going to be
happy at the end of election night I
mean I'm going to be depressed
regardless of what happens and it's just
a competition of of which future strikes
me as slightly more horrific and
honestly I think it's a dead heat well
uh I hope we'll have uh many more
updates from you as that depressing
evening approaches uh thank you very
much lonel oh it's pleasure to talk to
you
Freddy so from Donald Trump to the
Middle East uh last weekend three
American Service men and women were
killed by a drone attack in Jordan um
and the White House Joe Biden's
administration were very quick to point
the blame at Iran uh which has prompted
a usual chorus of concern about Iran's
activi
in the region uh and what is going on
with the unraveling situation in Gaza
and the ratcheting up of tensions um all
over the Middle East seemingly backed by
Iran's proxies Hezbollah the houthis and
so on I'm delighted to be joined Now by
Charlie gaml who is a former Diplomat
and a historian of Iran and Afghanistan
um Charlie do you think uh Western
Security sources are too quick to
immediately pin the blame directly on
Iran um whenever these attacks
happen um max lovely to be here uh I
would I would start by saying that that
no I don't think that's the case I think
Iran has a history going back until the
1980s of arming uh training and funding
these militia groups um and it uses it
as a as a policy to help project its
influence in the region so I think
there's a degree to which one can
overestimate the ties between these
groups I think particularly it's it's
sort of a sliding scale you have this
very strong long establ Rel established
relationship that Iran has with
Hezbollah and Lebanon and then you have
a slightly newer version of that uh in
Yemen with the houthis and then you have
something in between with these Iraqi
militias but I think it's possible to uh
to overstate the degree of control that
Iran can exert over these groups but I
think at the same time attributing these
attacks to Iran I think is a sensible
way to do this uh do you think that Iran
is capable of pulling them back because
there been been quite a lot of talk some
of it coming from Israeli sources
suggesting that Iran is no longer in
control of its proxies yeah that's
that's that's definitely I think
everything has to be taken on a case-by
Case basis and the degree to which Iran
can exert control over these groups I
think you'd have to look at each one I
think it's important to state that some
of the Iraqi militias have said that
they're going to hold off on attacks on
the Americans in Iraq uh and in the
region so as not to embarrass the
government in Baghdad and I think it's
important to State here that that the
relationship that Iran has with these
these groups is so close um and and for
example in in in Yemen Iranian senior
Iranian ballistic missile advisers have
been there for for for quite a long time
recently so this is a this is a very
very very close relationship there is
intermarriage between some of the
Iranian IC people and some of the
members of these groups of women are the
members of these groups um and that
relationship is very close there is a
danger that uh Iran is not able to
control them anymore but my sense is
right now Iran has a decent enough
control over them I think potentially
the exception is the houthis um and I
think there the houthis have sort of
publicly stated that you know they are
Keen to do their own thing and even
though they're friendly with Iran
they're not they don't want to be
totally beholden to Iran and I think if
there's an analogous situation here it's
the relationship between isi and the
Taliban so for a long time isi the
Pakistani intelligence Services were
arming and funding and training the
Taliban and that relationship was very
very deep but there but it wasn't
without its tensions and it wasn't
without some one side doing something
that uh that the is or the Taliban doing
something the isi didn't want to do so I
would say Iran is able to to control
these these groups but there is always
the danger that that control goes out of
out of hand or that one of these groups
does something that is a mistake and
actually ends up killing more US service
Personnel um so I think that's the
danger and if you look at the response
from both sides I think the the Iranian
foreign minister the Iranian um
Representatives the UN and the igc
leader have all come out in the last
couple of days with very similar
statements basically saying we don't
want a war but we're not fearful of a
war um and calling on the Americans to
stop their threatening language and
calling on the Americans to to back down
so there's this sense that both sides
are trying to have their cake and eat it
they both want to nibble up the food
chain um but at the same time um they
they are saying publicly and privately
look we we don't want a war and do you
think Iran has become uh Stronger geost
strategically since uh the October 7th
uh attacks Israel um or do you think
it's actually exposing just how many
enemies uh Iran has in the region the
Gulf States uh seem still opposed even
if they are nervous about what's going
on in Gaza I think that's that's a
really interesting point and I think the
last time I was on a spectator podcast
this was pre October 7th and I was I was
talking about the Ibrahim ACC cords I
was talking about Saudi Israeli
normalization Saudi Iranian
normalization obviously both of those
are the very small n um and my sense was
then was that there is a danger that
Iran becomes Iran's influence in the
region lessens if the Palestine issue
becomes less of a focal point for for
the world's attention that's something
that Iran likes to stand on and and sort
of project its influence through the
region say we're standing up for the pal
people of Palestine if America sort of
fully retrenched from the region that
would become less of an issue for Better
or For Worse if Saudi Arabia and Israel
normalize their ties there's two huge
powers in the Middle East both of whom
share an enemity of Iran if the ibraim
to sort of continue and I think they
probably will the Saudi Ira Saudi Israel
normalization is probably on hold for
the moment there was a danger
pre-october 7th that Iran was becoming
isolated and actually the enemies of
Iran were turning on sort of Iran as it
were and I think that was in the context
of America saying to the Saudis look you
know we're going to withdraw from the
region we would like to concentrate on
China um and we'd like you to sort of in
very simplistic terms to sort of take
control of the region and there was a
danger that Iran would become isolated
as a consequence of this so you know
speaking to people who were at Davos
recently and off the record
conversations with Iranians October the
7th has been a bit of a boon for Iran
strategically because it's allowed it
through its proxies to play a hugely
significant role on on on the global
stage through the houthis in Yemen to be
able to say to the Arab Street we're
standing up for the people of Palestine
and also not only we doing that we're
actually potentially crippling um global
Shipping and we're actually putting the
we're putting a really uncomfortable
ball in the West's Court which is Will
stop doing this if you agree to a
ceasefire and obviously the Iranians and
the huthis and everyone on that side is
aware that that's a really easy position
for them to take because it's very
difficult for America to agree a
ceasefire given that Israel under
Netanyahu won't agree to a ceasefire for
as long as Hamas are in existence and it
looks like Hamas will continue to be
existent so this has been I think a
strategic win for Iran um it's and
obviously off the back of its
relationships with Russia and and China
and I think it's really important to see
the sort of shadow of the Ukraine
conflict hanging over this conflict
because as America gets further involved
in the Middle East as potentially
European or UK assets get more involved
in the Middle East both in terms of time
and money that lessens the time and
money they have to spend on Ukraine that
lessens the appetite for the American
electorate to be involved in two
theaters in globally so that works to
Russia's Advantage if War fatigue can
set in on two fronts for the Americans
exactly and and so much so uh that that
would add weight to the idea that Iran
and possibly Russia uh had some role or
knowledge of the October 7th attacks uh
how much do you read into
that um my sense is if you look at the
attacks on October the 7th Iran is
Master if you look at the way it's
involved in in Ukraine and you look at
the way it was involved in Syria
militarily it uses drones I mean and
that's a bit of a USP for Iranian sort
of military Sops and the the the use of
drones in that in that war obviously was
was very kind of had a bit of a GC
signature all over it and it's I mean I
don't know for certain but but this
obviously works into favor of you have
to look at who benefits Russia benefits
Iran benefits Iran has a very good
relationship with Hamas Iran helped
Hamas and Damascus and Syria sort of
patch up their differences in 20122 so
Iran has played an important role with
in Hamas and this actually works to
lebanon's interest as well I mean if if
if there's a big war in Gaza uh Hamas
can take the Flack and Le and Hezbollah
can just sort of do play the role of
spoiler as opposed to the role of sort
of you know bearing the brunt of the
attack as it has done in the past so I
think if you look at who benefits and
then you take your reading on that
question from that I think you could say
well I would be surprised if there
wasn't some some knowledge of this
beforehand but again that's that's not
speaking from any concrete knowledge but
that's just looking at the cost benefit
analysis and who really does benefit and
it is Russia and it is Iran lastly
Charlie uh you sort of alluded to the
fact there that Israel uh if if Iran is
the winner uh of this Israel is the
loser not just because of the the
tragedy of October 7th but because of
the wider implications of the war right
now um Netanyahu is now a kind of global
bogeyman uh for many parts of the world
um Israel arguably has
overreached uh the Abraham Accords may
be revived but they're certainly on
pause at the moment um is it essentially
a case of when Iran wins Israel loses
and vice
versa I think a lot of that depends
depends on what American involvement in
the region looks like going forward and
and and I think you know blink's a very
astute Diplomat um Biden's got a lot of
experience in this regard the UK will
will play a big role in that in trying
to sort of go a little bit sort of to
the status quo Ane pre October the 7th I
think that Israel you know as UK US
troops and Western troops found in Iraq
and Afghanistan when you are involved in
a Messi counterinsurgency at some point
you had to start asking why are these
people fighting us and I think that that
which and what does that involve that
involves looking at the West Bank that
involves looking at Gaza and that's
where I think the Americans have been
quite wise even though it looks like
it's incredibly futile thing for blinkin
to talk about the two-state solution
while the Middle East is sort of going
up in Flames I think tying US policy to
the two-state solution is a sensible an
option as you can get in this regard but
in terms of does Iran win or does Iran
lose if Israel loses
um I don't know I think Iran Iran can be
seen as a sort of strategic genius or or
a blunderer I often think it's somewhere
in between and I think that they're very
good at playing the role of spoiler how
good they are at playing the role of
sort of actually a constructive role in
the region to bring things to a peaceful
conclusion with buying from all parties
I'm not sure given the length of emity
and the sort of the depth rather of
emity that exists in this conflict I'm
not sure how positive a role Iran can
play in that but but I think Israel has
got a an uphill struggle at the moment
in Gaza should it continue to want to to
achieve the aims that it set out for the
to the start which is to sort of destroy
Hamas completely which I'm not sure is
possible Charlie gaml thank you very
much for your um fascinating
insights now let's look to China and uh
the Chinese leader Xi Jinping who is
arguably or perhaps probably uh the most
powerful person in the world and yet we
don't really know an awful lot about the
way he thinks uh and who he really is uh
there's a useful new book that has come
out called the political thoughts of
xingping and it's written by two
academics uh Steve sang and Olivia CH
and they have uh tried to sort of
distill um Jing Ping's thought from
various CCP documents uh that have been
produced which are uh which tend to be
impossibly boring and difficult to read
um I'm delighted to be joined by Charles
Parson who is a former Diplomat uh and
an associate fellow at the Royal United
Services Institute um Charles uh you've
reviewed this book in The Spectator this
week and you start the review by saying
you were once asked um to sort of sum up
XI Zing Ping's thinking in one word and
you you came up with the word
solipsistic uh can you explain why you
chose that word yes well I don't mean in
the strictly philosophical sense sense
of the word but I mean in in the sense
that's used in in in sort of common
conversation namely supremely
self-centered and thinking that the
whole world R and its reality revolves
around um China and Chinese
thinking yes and in this book we get a
little sort of insight into that uh
solipsism uh and you make you you make a
good point about how boring uh these and
difficult to read these documents are I
think you quote someone saying uh it's
like eating Rhino sausage I think was
the the term um why why are I just want
to ask why do you think these documents
are so impenetrable um is it half
deliberate uh is it just how propaganda
works when it's been going on for so
long I don't think they're in
impenetrable to the um to most Chinese
who are used to brought up on this diet
of rhinoceros sausage um and they're not
necessarily impenetrable to the likes of
Steve tang and and Olivia Chong and
those of us who spend our life munching
away at this rather strange diet um I
mean I think the first thing to say
about of course is it's in Chinese which
is a very difficult language and Joe and
Li used to say that was the first level
of coding um but then of course you've
got a lot of marxist doctrine that
you've got to get your mind around and
you've got to get your mind around many
of the slogans and expressions that the
the Communist Party intends to simplify
its thought into so it might talk about
the seven don't speaks and you have to
understand what the seven don't speaks
are uh or the two becomes so there's a
certain amount of hard graph you you
have to do to begin to read these things
what are the seven do speaks well and
this is probably one of the most famous
Chinese documents of the last decade it
came out in April 2013 and it's known U
colloquially as document number nine
because that was its number Central
document but it it lays out the seven
values of the main seven values that
underpin Western Society uh and
excoriates them all and is that good
Communists and others should should stew
these and see see things from the
through true eyes of the Chinese
Communist party so things like media
Freedom or independent Justice or um our
Western economic system or political
system to totally not not not to be
followed you shouldn't speak about them
yeah uh well one term you mentioned in
the review uh and forgive me if I'm
pronouncing it wrong is
chania uh which translates as everything
under under Heaven um and this is an
important concept for z uh and and the
CCP um can you explain what that's all
about yes um the pronunciation if I may
is cha but but um it was good
approximation if that doesn't sound too
patronizing sorry um but yeah so this
comes in in the section on on on foreign
relations and uh the concept of chenar
is a very old one goes back many
centuries where the Chinese
perceive or perceive an Ideal World in
which China is Central which the emperor
um rules serenely and engages to the
benefit of um the non-chinese beyond
beyond beyond China and you you get
peace and prosperity provided that you
basically tow the line and don't go
against China's interests so that's
that's the basic concept um don't don't
rock the boat and certainly don't rock
the Chinese boat and everything will be
well and finally Charles do you think uh
that Z is tremendously bright he's
obviously very uh intelligent you know
you don't get to lead a world superpower
without having quite a lot of cunning
and and and ability um certainly seems
to have a lot of organizational ability
um but this solit ISM you speaks of
speak speaks to a kind of limited mind
does it
not well yes I think you're absolutely
right to say that he's um very sharp
politically I mean the way he has
elbowed his way to to supreme power to a
position where he really is um up there
with with MAO in in terms of um you know
personal power Etc that bespeaks um a
very great
determination very clear idea of how how
to attain it and a complete ruthlessness
um but a lot of people within China um
say well he's not that bright he doesn't
really understand the economy and the
economies in any country I suppose is
the most important thing um you know
that we we don't have a a great deal of
insights into that but one of one of the
best ones is actually on on Wikileaks as
an American cable talking about um
someone who grew up with in the same
sort of mure as C Jinping and generally
then he wasn't seen as particularly
bright and um but but you know what he
was was was very loyal despite his
personal background of his father having
been persecuted extremely badly by the
Chinese Communist Party um one might say
an almost of Stockholm syndrome but but
he's um and I think also you know how
bright is he he's made a few mistakes I
mean CO's an obvious example I I would
say that um throwing off cjun ping donga
Ping's policy of hide and B on the
foreign stage a little bit early frankly
it's a bit like playing political
grandmother's footstep steps I mean you
don't rush to to touch Grandma until
you're shut and you can get there before
they turn around Well the West has
turned around and and become very um
anti-china as as a result of I think
breaking cover too early so there's
plenty of mistakes there um but
politically uh there's one sharp elbow
cookie and are those mistakes an
opportunity uh for the West I mean is is
the fact that jingping is not some
bismar uh of the 21st Century uh does
that suggest that perhaps China's rise
is more
stoppable um than we might
assume well um again you know it depends
what you mean by China's rise one wishes
all Prosperity upon the Chinese people
etc etc but um and actually to me I
think the the biggest um impediment to
their rise is their economic system and
the fact that I don't think it is
possible um under that sort of system
eventually to to uh have an economy that
is sustainable enough to to to um you
know promote the sort of U one world
domination if that doesn't sound too
dramatic that that c Jinping is is aimed
for you can't be the number one
superpower unless you've got a highly
successful economy and we're now seeing
the economy entering the phase that was
predicted by a number of us which said
that um you know the economic model is
is broken and that's what shiin Ping
himself said back in 2013 when he
introduced all these economic reforms
about sort of 385 reforms on under 60
chapters God knows what but they haven't
been implemented now if it if he was
saying it was broken 10 years ago uh and
you haven't changed it then I think it's
fair to conclude it's still broken and I
think we're seeing that in in the
problems that they're running into now
so um you know other factors I think the
West free and open countries because
it's not just west Japan India and other
countries are beginning to see the
problems and the threats and are taking
measures against it so you know when you
say is this an opportunity the thing
about opportunity is that that sounds
rather positive and I I I don't think
that's the picture we have I mean we
have a world which I'm afraid is um You
can call it deris risking if you like or
diverging or decoupling or anything
beginning with d but it we're all going
to be poorer as a result um but
nevertheless not as poor I suspect both
spiritually and possibly economically as
we might be if cin Ping's Vision came to
full
fruition uh on that uh slightly
terrifying note thank you very much
Charleson for coming on to spectator
TV that is it from spectator TV thank
you very much for watching I hope you
found it uh interesting and entertaining
a little bit entertaining anyway uh if
you enjoyed the show you must subscribe
again to remind you uh to do that you
hit the Subscribe button at the bottom
of the screen join uh well over 300,000
um people who already do that uh and
then hit the Bell icon to get the
reminders uh whenever we release a new
episode that's all for now uh thank you
very much please come back next
[Music]
week